ladies and gentlemen from CNN rep
Alexandria ocasio-cortez supports
Biden's re-election bid
congratulations AOC is an establishment
chill that's what you get and of course
she's going to preface this a little bit
with like no I'm saying like
hypothetically I would if yeah yeah this
is what this is how politics goes AOC is
this young upstart who's challenging the
machine and as a real leftist then as
soon as she gets into office she starts
ponying up to the establishment you see
that video where like she changes her
Vote or something like that you know
it's been a while since like Pelosi
yells at her and then her vote changes
or something I don't remember exactly
but here's the story because we want to
make sure the context is clear
Democratic Democratic rep AOC said
Thursday that she will support President
Joe Biden's reelection bid given the
challengers he currently faces in the
primary author Marion Williamson an
Environmental Lawyer and anti-vaccine
activist Robert F Kennedy have launched
campaigns when asked on the Pod save
America podcast whether she would back
Biden she said I believe given that
field yes
amazing there's your uh leftist there's
your new up-and-coming Progressive I
guarantee you in a few years she's gonna
start moving up people have talked about
maybe she'll run for Senate she got
millions of followers she is going to be
as establishment as establishment can be
she'll be coming out being like stop
insulting my banker friends the people
who run the Federal Reserve are good
people trying to make America she's
gonna be like Elizabeth Warren yeah
she's gonna just say whatever is she
gonna say so the Press says something
positive and then she tricks people into
voting for she's already basically there
congratulations she's also super
valuable to the political Elite like
when it comes to the establishment her
her reach is insane she's incredibly
inspirational to a lot of young
left-wing women I mean our audience is
ridiculous I don't know partially you
can probably blame uh a part of the
right for doing that but she's really
really valuable for them so naturally I
think that direction and they would they
would give her as much power as she
needs and all that stuff because they
want her she's she's very establishment
she's their actual Pied Piper in that
she's playing that little flute and
dancing all the progressives right into
the hands of the neoliberal
establishment right you know it's an
interesting question because when AOC
first won her primary back and I think
it was like 2018. I thought it was a
good thing I was like good get these
establishment Democrat chills out
Crowley was a prominent like uh fourth
in line in the Democratic party or
whatever she she gets rid of him she
takes over and I said she may be you
know leftist or whatever but I'll take a
left populist over a corporatist neolib
shill and warmonger and what does she
turn out to be all that and worse
terminals any there's a problem as they
go in there get co-opted I don't even
blame her I blame the system itself we
need term limits because she should be
two and out yeah but you know what it is
it's AOC has nothing going for her does
she have Merit does she have talent and
ability to a certain degree answer is
yes but would she be anything other than
a bartender if she did not get elected
what we see with so many members of
Congress and politicians is that they
don't have the merits to do anything
other than win the beauty pageant and
once they do they're terrified look if I
don't win my re-election what happens
next right where's Madison cawthorne
right he's in the news every day he's
got something going for him he loses the
primary and now he's no longer relevant
so if you're someone who wants to be
who wants who wants to matter
and you don't have the ability politics
is your game and then what happens is
they get in and they're like okay I
can't lose this Nancy Pelosi probably
goes to AOC and says we will do
everything in our power to make sure you
lose unless you play ball
do you want to be the up-and-coming
young star of the democratic party or do
you want to go back to the bar and she's
like please Nancy I'll do anything you
say and here you go I know Matt Gates is
I don't know if these their their
friends or whatever but he's mentioned
to us that he would enjoy having her
come on the show with him at some point
desantises people won't even come on
this show she actually mentioned ilhan
Omar specifically I remember that and he
so they they have a bond of some sort
probably because they're young and in
Congress they're they're like all this
Freedom caucus and maybe they've worked
together a little bit as well as well I
would be shocked if she actually said
yes I would be really happy about it I'm
just thinking of ways to head it off at
the past before 20 years go by and she
is fully establishment that's scary like
job mentality she endorsed The Bite in a
year and a half out come on yeah but uh
with a caveat that at this stage with
those two people that he's running
against I would what's her opposition
RFK I don't know well that's how you
know that they're full of it like
Newsome does announce too uh she would
go new you some for sure yeah yeah the
thing about RFK is um yeah I disagree
with them a lot of things but he's he's
he's more populist he's speaking to the
people and so it's like oh okay I get it
for her to be like oh man I'd rather
have Biden are you kidding you're that
Biden come on warmonger establishment
come on man yeah I would take Marion
Williamson over both of them to be
completely honest I think she's very
nice oh she'd be a good guess we've
invited her several times she's actually
very very nice I have a lot of respect
for her I feel so bad for how the media
mistreats her and how people make fun of
her uh that's unfair she may be wrong
about things as most people are but she
she seems to be a genuine nice person
who really does want to make a
difference I think we would all benefit
from having that conversation with her
and she set the record straight about
Crystal she doesn't actually own
crystals but but this is what I do but
this is
lady and it was so sad to see her be
like I don't understand I don't own any
crystals I've never done anything with
this why are they saying that about me
it's like welcome to the political Arena
yeah now now yeah Marianne where I'm a
fan everything bad they said about you
now think about what you think of Donald
Trump
welcome to the same game Donald Trump is
far from perfect and we know he said
some nasty things but when they come at
you and they say you're the crystal
woo-woo lady think about what they call
Donald Trump and how it's not real and
then people come out and they're like
but a court found that he was
responsible for a rape 30 years ago and
it's like dude spare me your Ultra
liberal New York District ruling that a
30 year old case with no evidence it
makes him responsible it's just these
are it's political nonsense yeah that's
the name of the game yeah it's always
interesting seeing people actually wake
up usually I mean I don't know if they
fully get out of it but her seeing how
she was treated by the media and just
kind of putting that or if she was on
the show definitely putting that into
perspective with her to say look at look
at what we're dealing with you dealt
with that for just a brief moment we
deal with that the right deals with that
every day right this unfair treatment
from the massive media machine Tulsi
gabbard's another one that had that big
time uh in the face of like what am I up
against totally woke up when they uh she
called out Kamala Harris and basically
tanked her opportunity to become
president if she ever even no but it was
before that it was it was Bernie yeah
yeah they called her a Russian asset and
she's like dude she's like a cur was
colonel in the middle they they viewed
her as an up-and-coming young star for
the Democratic party and then when it
came to Bernie versus Hillary said
Bernie and they were like you've just
ended your career and now she's like uh
Entertainer basically remember how she
called out Clinton Hillary Clinton she
called her like the ultimate warmonger
the queen of warmongers she like just
just absolutely you should call it
something or worse than that right yeah
it was it was re she excoriated her I
don't I don't have to find out the
actual quote right in front but she
absolutely excoriated her it was one of
the most brilliant political one of the
most Brave political things that I've
ever seen anyone do someone actually
running on the Democratic ticket calling
Hillary Clinton it was Queen of
warmonger yeah queen of War mongers
literally just carrying her apart and
after that when I saw that I was like
look she got terrible takes on the
two-way but I back her if she's going
after Clinton you know see the this is
what this is what I like right we have
uh we had we did the culture War show
today and we had uh Stephen Bonnell uh
Destiny he's a liberal guy
um even after the show we were hanging
out and we were having disagreements but
Destiny is an honest guy he could be
wrong about something sometimes we all
are but I know that if we if we come and
have a conversation he's actually going
to try and make a point that he thinks
is true and honestly assess what we are
saying to him then you have the actual
cultural left which is people like AOC
who will just lie cheat and steal for
political power you have people like
Tulsi gabbard who was being honest in
what her views were and probably wrong
on something same as most people are but
was being honest to you on why she
thought those things and was genuinely
listening to you they're they're it's
almost like
the culture War factions we always try
to Define what they are but I can tell
you one characteristic at the very least
is if you hold leftist political
opinions but tell the truth you're right
wing
plain and simple that's how it goes I
was actually talking with Destiny about
he said it was funny that um you know
when we do these shows with leftists
they make the Assumption of what my
political opinions are because in their
world if you don't follow their
narrative you're right wing so they'll
say things like I'm pro-life or
something like that which is like I'm
like none of these like these things are
not true you don't know what my opinions
actually are these people make things up
I mean come on like what it would take
to endorse someone like Biden you know
what I mean and and for that matter I'm
seeing a lot of that with the with the
DeSantis people as well
I'll have a conversation with people
support Trump
and some people are fervently culty for
Trump and it and it is kind of creepy
yeah but most of the prominent Trump
people will absolutely concede Trump's
faults because it is the authentic and
appropriate way to approach the
conversation hey you don't have to think
about Trump let me talk to you and maybe
convince you that there's still some of
that positives here the DeSantis people
it's like they're they're just identical
to Democrats no matter what DeSantis
does he is he is uh infallible he's he's
unimpeachable so descendants makes a
mistake and they will say it was
actually a good thing I wonder if the
people you're talking about we say the
DeSantis people you mean like people
that are following well and people in
this campaign hardcore followers on
Twitter maybe that I wonder if what
they're doing is it's like an AI or a
foreign agent sowing descent between
DeSantis and you because you have a show
and a voice so if they see some
contention they're gonna be like Oh I'm
gonna make Tim angry and be like to say
this is great you and then you you
think that it's the sadness is somehow
connected with that it is insane
responsible there's no way to know that
I do because they have verification
Badges and profiles that say working for
The Descendants campaign those then
maybe but that's who I'm talking about
that seems like a a pretty big giveaway
right yeah and so when I said when I say
something semi-annocuous like wow I
can't believe this thing happened and
they start just attacking me on Twitter
I'm like what why are you attacking me
and so like well it's it's it's you get
the point it really does feel like they
are very much like acting as Democrats
do towards Trump yeah it seems to me
like they have like a book of rules that
they've written out and studied but they
don't really get the nuances of why the
rules work but they're just following
them all expecting them to be you know
to make them cool in that way is just
like we all see it's not working yeah
it's like a it's a list right you gotta
check every single box and if you differ
such as Destiny who probably differs a
lot from a lot of people on the left
you're kicked out of that cult when it
comes to the extreme left wing if you
differ at all you're completely out you
know Tim I was talking
um to one of your viewers the other day
I just ran into him in the street uh
libertarian kind of guy you know
disagrees with people on the right
disagrees with people on the left but he
was talking to leftist protesters gender
you know cold protesters and he was just
saying he was just asking them some
basic questions and you might agree with
them on some stuff but they were just
calling him a fascist and telling him to
get the hell out of there even though he
might have agreed on some things oh yeah
because it's a cult thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time